un deux roues dans la ville ça pourrait
être le titre d'un film ou d'un roman
mais ce qui est sûr c'est que ce film où
ce roman ceci est un roman d'aventurés
car pour tous ceux qui comme moi au
moins une fois dans les environs peu
compris utiliser une petite reine pour
aller ou bien travailler ou bien se
promener bien tout le monde s'est aperçu
des problèmes que pose la circulation
d'un deux roues dans une grande ville
comment c'est d'ailleurs par les
rapports que le deux roues entretien
avec les automobilistes et soutenu liste
en l'air d'oublier un peu les vélos
c'est comme si les oubliait quoi
qu'est-ce que vous avez attention vous
avez eu des accidents déjà on prend avec
les voitures non non non mais des fois
ça passe pas loin quand même qu'on
ferait que les automobilistes apprennent
à respecter les vélos chez lui la ville
appartient à l'automobile ah oui à un
vélo
pas aussi difficile notamment des listes
qu'à une évidence en voiture c'est fini
qu'est ce qu'on pourrait faire d'après
vous pour améliorer la circulation des
deux roues dans les villes peut-être
et créer des couloirs spéciaux bien j'ai
pas moi
pour moi
favoriser le
d'euros par rapport à la voiture au
moindre
c'est le moyen de locomotion le plus
pratique en ville on pourrait aussi
créer
des aires de stationnement et 6 pour les
pour les deux roues
créer des parkings pour les vélos créer
des pistes cyclables dans les villes ce
sont deux des mesures proposées par jean
pierre fourcade en faveur des vélos et
des cyclomoteurs de moins de cinquante
centimètres cubes contre les
embouteillages contre la pollution pour
économiser l'énergie
et puis aussi pour son côté pratique la
petite reine a réussi à résister à
l'automobile mêmes continuent de régner
dans le coeur des français
il faut donc améliorer son utilisation
dit le ministre de l'equipement premier
souci séparer le plus souvent possible
la circulation entre les deux roues et
les automobiles en conséquence on va
créer encore plus de pistes cyclables
sur les nationales les crédits seront
multipliées par deux créations aussi de
passagers spéciaux pour les vélos
permettant de traverser les échangeurs
et les souterrains interdit aux cycles
le plus souvent des circuits spéciaux
seront tracés pour les promeneurs ou les
sportifs à bicyclette dans les forêts et
les parcs autour des villes les
expériences comme celle de la rochelle
où les habitants peuvent utiliser
gratuitement des vélos de la
municipalité dans les centres villes
ces expériences seront poursuivis enfin
mesures importantes pour les
banlieusards qui utilisent leurs deux
roues entre leur domicile et la gare
près de 5500 places de stationnement
vont être aménagés avec des systèmes
antivol et des abris contre les
intempéries
[Musique]